And when thou would solace gather-
When our child's first accents flow-
Wilt thou teach her to say father?
Though his care she must forgo.
Those are the words of a poet named Lord
Byron written about his daughter Ada as he
was separating from her mother
just weeks after Ada was born.
Ada would marry and go on to become Ada King,
Countess of Lovelace or known as Ada
Lovelace and she's often referred to
as the first ever computer programmer.
That is all I had heard about her
until recently when I wondered, what does
that really mean? and is it even true?
Well the best way to find out is to
read the document that she's famous for.
It's the only paper that she published
and it's called Sketch of the Analytical
Engine. It is this document that will allow us to
understand Ada's role in the history of computing
so in this video I would like
to go through it with you.
It describes the analytical engine invented
by Charles Babbage which was a monstrously
ambitious steam-powered computer. I will
cover the mechanical aspects of the engine
just enough to be able to understand some
of the programs that Ada wrote for it.
Gossip about her private affairs, gambling, and
interesting philosophies, although fascinating,
will have to be left for another video.
A Sketch of the Analytical Engine was
published in 1843 and the first part of
it was a paper published by an Italian
mathematician who would actually go on
to become the prime minister of Italy, Luigi
Menabrea. Ada translated his work into english
and then added her own notes to it and these
notes were twice as long as the original paper.
At the time ada had already been acquainted
with Charles Babbage for a number of years
and had been working alongside
him to understand the engine.
It was in these notes that she included an
algorithm that could use the engine to compute
Bernoulli numbers and it is this which is called
the first computer program. She also notes that
the engine could be used to do things
other than arithmetic and computations.
She has this idea that quantities other than
numbers could be represented in the engine
and could therefore go on to be used for things
like composing music. This insight and vision a
hundred years before Alan Turing would come along
with his own ideas of the modern computer are
really quite remarkable and is something that she
definitely deserves to be credited for as well.
So let's start at the beginning. It was Charles
Babbage who was the mastermind behind this
first computer and he was frustrated by
mistakes that crept into logarithm tables
used back then for calculations. He wanted to
"execute by means of machinery the mechanical
branch of scientific labors, reserving for pure
intellect that which depends on reasoning".
So really he wants to free
up the scientist's mind.
Charles Babbage first came
up with the difference engine
and in this example here we have the series of
whole square numbers 1, 4, 9, 16, 25 and so on.
If we find the difference between each of these
numbers we'll get a new series 3, 5, 7, 9, 11 and
the difference between each of these numbers is
always equal to 2. It is shown in this table here
and from this if we were given just the
numbers 2, 5, and 9 we would be able to
reconstruct this entire series of square
numbers just through a series of additions.
For the machine we would have three dials A, B
and C and also two hammers. So if we start by
placing needle C on 2, needle B on 5 and needle
A on 9, then the hammer on C will strike twice
adding 2 onto needle B. So B will now read
7, it will then strike its hammer 7 times
adding 7 onto 9 and giving us the result
16. If we recommence these operations
beginning with the needle C which is always to
be left on 2 we will successively reproduce the
series of whole square numbers by
means of a very simple mechanism.
Babbage himself ran out of money to ever finish
building the difference engine although he did
have a small model of it. Since then some
clever people have finished it for him
and made a complete version. Babbage kind of
got distracted by his idea for a second type of
engine, one that could do a lot more and was much
more ambitious, this was the analytical engine.
The analytical engine can perform addition,
subtraction, multiplication and division
and "is therefore capable of performing
every species of numerical calculation".
For the analytical engine we have a series
of vertical columns consisting of a number of
circular disks. The first disk represents units,
the second tens, the third hundreds and so on.
Babbage's notes showed as many as 40 disks
so you could have quite some precision. They
haven't had the idea of using binary
numbers so everything is in decimal.
We denote these columns with V for variable and
for example if we wanted to add the numbers on V1
and V4 together we would then place the result
on a third column we could call that V7.
The act of adding the numbers together will
occur at a place on the engine called the mill.
"The mill is the portion
of the machine which works
and the columns of variables constitute that
where the results are represented and arranged".
So in modern computing notation the mill may
be called the CPU and the columns of variables,
this big extension out the back of the machine,
would be called the store or the memory.
You may wonder how the machine knows which
operations to perform and which variables
to include and the solution has been taken from
Jacquard's apparatus. What they're talking about
here is using punch cards that were first used in
Jacquard's loom, something that was used to make
intricate patterns in lace and other materials
by using a series of cards as the instructions.
There are two main types of cards that will
allow us to program the engine, the first
are the operation cards and these are telling
the machine if you want to perform addition,
subtraction, multiplication or division and the
second type of card is the card of the variables
which indicate to the machine the columns
on which the results are to be represented.
There's then a fairly brief example and you may
even want to call this the first computer program
since it's the first example in the notes but
it's much more simple than the Bernoulli program
which will appear later. In this we have two
simultaneous equations and say that we want
to solve for x. Well we can rearrange these
equations into this fraction here, then we
assign our eight variables to eight different
columns. n and n' have been represented twice
probably because they will need to be used
twice in separate parts of the calculation.
This table then gives an idea of the cards that
would be needed to execute this. Here we have the
number of the operation so first step, second
step, third step and so on then in the next
column here these are our set of operation
cards. They're just saying that we're either
performing a multiplication, a subtraction or a
division. And these are the cards of the variables
telling the machine which variables are
involved in each of these operations,
so we have here V2 times V4 and that
result is going to be put on the column V8.
This box here just shows what we're doing.
That was the step of multiplying d by n'.
Following all these steps and the last one
will end up giving you the result for x.
Since the cards just tell the machine what columns
and what operations to do we still need to
enter the initial numerical data ourselves
so there's still a little bit of
room for a human error in here.
What's interesting is that the method of running
the engine is actually Turing complete which
wasn't a phrase that existed at the time but
essentially means it would be able to perform
any computation although in this case
it is limited by being steam powered.
We are now on to the first of Ada's notes,
this one is note A. It is quite philosophical
and poetic. She says in it that "the machine
might act upon other things besides number...
Supposing for instance that the fundamental
relations of pitched sounds in the science of
harmony and musical composition were susceptible
of such expression and adaptations the engine
might compose elaborate and scientific pieces
of music of any degree of complexity or extent".
She says that "whether the inventor of this engine
had any such views in his mind while working out
the invention or whether he may subsequently
ever have regarded it under this phase
we do not know but it is one that forcibly
occurred to ourselves on becoming acquainted with
the means through which analytical combinations
are actually attained by the mechanism".
She's saying that there are some
things that are very clear to her
but she's not sure if Charles
Babbage even shares the same views.
She even speaks of the intrinsic
beauty of the mathematics behind this.
She says that "this science constitutes
the language through which alone we can
adequately express the great
facts of the natural world...
Those who thus think on mathematical truth as the
instrument through which the weak mind of a man
can most effectually read his Creator's works
will regard with special interest all that can
tend to facilitate the translation of its
principles into explicit practical forms".
I love this sentence here where she says that
"the analytical engine weaves algebraic patterns
just as the Jacquard loom weaves flowers and
leaves". She's seeing how they can take the
beautiful patterns from lace and material and
translate that into the beauty of mathematics.
The other big idea that she deserves to
be remembered for is recognizing that the
analytical engine is unlike anything before it.
she says here that "the engine does not occupy
common ground with mere calculating machines"
and she spends a lot of the notes pointing out
the differences between the difference engine
and this much more powerful analytical engine.
Doing so was important in its own right but it
was also slightly political in a way because
Charles Babbage was trying really hard to get
enough funding to build his analytical engine
and with his track record of running
out of money to build the difference
engine he was really struggling to convince
people of its value and of its difference.
Ada then says something which still rings
true today in the pursuit of trying to
convince people that doing research or building
machines or projects that might not have as much
immediate value can still bring a lot of value
down the line that we are not even aware of.
She says "those who incline to very strictly
utilitarian views may perhaps feel that the
peculiar powers of the analytical engine bear
upon questions of abstract and speculative science
rather than upon those involving everyday and
ordinary human interests. These persons being
likely to possess but little sympathy, or possibly
acquaintance, with any branches of science which
they do not find to be useful (according to
their definition of that word) may conceive
that the undertaking of that engine now that the
other one is already in progress would be a barren
and unproductive laying out of yet more money and
labor" however she continues that while some of
the results of the analytical engine may be known
now "others which it may not yet be possible to
foresee but which would be brought forth by
the daily increasing requirements of science
and with practical acquaintance with the powers
of the engine were it in actual existence".
She sounds like anyone today trying to justify
some of these more abstract or blue sky research
ideas in mathematics or even things like
investing in space technology and exploration.
Unfortunately due to the lack of funds and lack
of mechanical and technical abilities back then
they weren't able to actually build the
analytical engine and I wonder what kind
of insights and developments might have happened
if they actually had one of these in existence.
It would be quite a long time before
we would converge back on these ideas.
Let's move on to Ada's last note the famous
note G. It starts off with a comment that is
surprisingly relevant here she says that
"in considering any new subject there is
frequently a tendency first to overrate what
we find to be already interesting or remarkable
and secondly by a sort of natural reaction
to undervalue the true state of the case
when we do discover that our notions have
surpassed those that were really tenable".
She may be talking about the engine and
not wanting to overstate its abilities
but the sentiment also is true for her role in the
history of computing. With the claims that she is
the first ever computer programmer perhaps she has
been sometimes overrated but then when people look
more into the case and start to say well you
know Charles Babbage has written programs of
his own in some of his notes there is a risk
to undervalue the true work that Ada has done
and we shouldn't do that because through
these notes I hope that it comes across
that she speaks with intelligence, with a lot
of knowledge of the analytical engine and of its
potential in a way that nobody else at the time
did and she definitely deserves to be valued.
And now finally we get to the really juicy
stuff which is this computer program to compute
the numbers of Bernoulli. The Bernoulli numbers
are involved with trying to calculate the sum
of positive integers to any given power.
Throughout history a lot of people tried
to do this and it was really difficult. Jacob
Bernoulli came up with a way to do this which
wasn't quite easy but at least
was easier than any other method.
He found that the sum of the first positive n
integers to any given power followed a pattern
and the coefficients of each term in this pattern
could be broken down into two factors. One set
of these factors the As could be obtained
from Pascal's triangle and the other set,
the Bs were called the Bernoulli numbers and
they themselves followed a pattern and could
be worked out using what's in the box up here. Ada
herself acknowledges in the notes that this is a
rather complicated example to be giving and not
that easy to follow the mathematical derivation
but she gives it as a way to illustrate
the very powerful abilities of the engine.
Her program computes these Bernoulli numbers and
it does so in terms of all the preceding ones.
She says that she "appends to this note a
diagram and table containing the details
of the computation for B7 given B1,
B3 and B5, and this is that program.
It's computing B to the 2n minus 1 in the case
of n being equal to 4. We have the number of
operation that we're up to and we have the
operation cards in here, multiply, subtract,
add and divide. We then have the variable cards
telling us which variables are involved in the
operation and where their result will go. We also
have this indication of change in the value on any
variable to keep track of variable columns that
are changing. We have our statement of results
to see what step in the computation we are up to
and then we have written here what our variables
actually are. In our case there will be six inputs
into the program. We will need to put in 1, 2 our
n which is 4 and B1, B3 and B5. That's what we
need to get to B7 although we are actually working
out these values as we go, if we have stopped
earlier in the process before we got to B7.
In this very first step where we multiply V2
by V3 we multiply 2 by n and we put the result
2n onto these three columns here because we're
going to want to use those later. We return the
two and the n back to where they came from because
we're also going to want to use those again.
In the case where we don't use the value again
we replace it with a zero. So we proceed through
some of the steps of the algebra here and the last
line in this first section here is doing n minus
one equal to three. We're taking our column where
n is stored so it was initially four and we're
subtracting one from it to be left with a new n
which is equal to three. Because n is now equal to
3 we're going to continue on the process and then
in the next step we'll decrease n to 2 and so on.
The section of lines down here 13 to 23 are very
interesting because every time n increases we just
need to do an additional repetition of these
operations 13 to 23. Because of that when n is
bigger than 2, 25 operation cards are used but no
more are needed regardless of how great n may be.
We will however have to add more variable
cards every time n goes up and Ada refers
to this as being a cycle of operations and since
these operations use the same pairs of columns
they are actually a cycle of variable cards
so this computer kind of has loops. It might
not be a for loop or a while loop but it is
a loop of cards that can be fed back into
the machine to continue computing the same
cycle of operations over and over again and
down here she shows what that looks like.
She says that "applying the notation for cycles
we may express the operations for computing the
numbers of the newly in the following manner".
For B1, B3, B5 and B7 we all have the same initial
set of seven operations, we finish with the same
pair of operations at the end, in the middle we
might have this set of operations from 8 to 12
and then a cycle of operations repeating those
from line 13 to 23 with a general formula down
here to compute any Bernoulli number. And what
you're looking at here is the seed of computer
programming that would go on to be so prevalent
and so important to run our modern world.
Ada died nine years after the paper was
published but nobody involved in the
project lived long enough to see the dream
be realized in fact we still haven't built
a version of the analytical engine although
I think it is still a dream of many people.
Ada was motivated and highly intelligent and
she was definitely the first person to clearly
communicate the ideas of a substantial computer
program. Charles Babbage had of course written
smaller programs in his own notes since he is the
person who came up with how the engine would work
and he did help Ada with a lot of the
mathematics but it was her who wrote it down
and wrote it down in a way that made it clear what
this engine was capable of and maybe it was her
who saw more than Babbage did what really the
potential was that they were dealing with.
It was very rare in these times for a woman to
even have a mathematical education but Ada did
and the reason that she did was because Ada's
mother tried very hard to steer Ada away
from becoming like her poet father Lord Byron.
She didn't want ada to study poetry or literature
or things like that, instead she steered
her into studying mathematics and science
hoping that that wouldn't result in her sharing
the same madness that ada's mother saw in ada's
father. However it wasn't so easy to completely
remove poetic tendencies from Ada because she saw
her approach kind of as a poetic science. Perhaps
it was those poetic tendencies that allowed her
to see the far-reaching potentials of
this technology and to see beyond its pure
mathematical abilities. In the end Ada chose to
be buried alongside her father and although their
accomplishments were very different, I guess
there was a thread that tied them together.
Thanks as always to my Patreon supporters
for making these videos possible
and a reminder that i've started
a podcast over on my Patreon
called Natural Wonders and there
are five episodes up already.
A special shout out to today's
Patreon Cat of the Day, Punkrock.
Thanks for watching and I
hope to see you next time :)